depuis le 16 mars dernier une grande
majorité des français est bloqué à la
maison sans pouvoir sortir pour tenter
d'endiguer l'épidémie mais si vos coûts
comprennent l'importance de cette
assignation à résidence pour d'autres il
est plus difficile de tenir en place et
pour braver les restrictions de
l'attestation de déplacement mises en
place par le gouvernement certains
n'hésitent pas à inventer des excuses
qui parfois sont à la limite de la
mauvaise foi un gendarme explique par
exemple avoir contrôlé un automobiliste
qui roulait à 15 km de chez lui et voilà
son excuse il nous a expliqué qu'il
avait eu une absence qui n'avait pas
fait attention et qu'ils avaient
continué à rouler plein sud plus tard
ils contrôlent un couple qui fait ses
courses à 80 kilomètres de son domicile
les deux contrevenants ont expliqué le
plus sérieusement du monde aux gendarmes
qu'il ne connaissait que ce magasin sans
compter ceux qui prennent carrément les
forces de l'ordre pour des jambons on a
eu aussi des gens qui nous ont dit qu'il
n'avait pas entendu parler à la télé du
confinement parce qu'il ne regardait que
netflix les gendarmes qui ont dû aussi
expliqué à quatre jeunes hommes que le
charbon pour la chicha ne faisait pas
partie des produits de première
nécessité et un autre jeune qui promet
en laisse son lapin que la dérogation
n'était valable que pour les chiens
comme quoi l'ennui développe la
créativité elle ça vous fait rire ah ça
c'est énorme a au bout et on apprend des
choses dans l'émission ça c'est
incroyable le mec qui a dit j'étais pas
au con du confinement je regarde que
netflix le gars je suis sorti acheter du
charbon à chicha c'est génial il a une
erreur d'adressent de leur gps même à 80
kilomètres de chez eux c'est quand même
magique l'achat de kilomètres de chez
lui dire car les garder c'est génial
un adolescent a dix qui a expliqué qu'il
rendait chez un copain et qu'il en avait
marre de jouer à la console depuis vingt
jours qu'il voulait rentrer chez lui ces
jets de l'armée
c'est exceptionnel c'est ses excuses
c'est très très fort un brûlot
franchement et c'est incroyable mais on
vous le rappelle les chéris restez chez
vous là on prend la rigolade mais le
plus important c'est vraiment adoré se
finira probablement pour les quatre
raisons qui ont été données sur
l'attestation oui bonjour nous restez
chez vous chantiez moins d'accord moi
jamais dans le xvème à paris il fait
très beau quand je sors on voit pas que
c'est le confinement il ya un nombre de
gens dans la rue mais c'est incroyable
et non pas des gens des gens qui se
trimballent mais on voit bien qui
flânent ils sont pas en train de faire
qui vont bosser n'importe quoi ils sont
beaux ils sont tranquilles quoi